my name is cecilia chan
people said i brought chinese food to
america children's child both french
since election brought chinese
[Music]
this is all my sisters that's me
in 1959 i came to san francisco
visiting my sister sophie
we leave the edge of chinatown
the first time i noticed the food i said
is this a chinese food my sister said
yes i look at the venue
chops egg foo
i'm originally born near shanghai and i
say i don't remember we tasted any of
this in china so my sister said they say
american
chinese food
i decided i want to introduce my
chinese food to
usa
i opened the bathroom
on 1960 this is manually with the mayor
masconi the customers oh my goodness the
food tastes a total difference a lot of
dishes that we've never seen before we
had hot and sour soup the lettuce cup
the pot sticker picking up i was the
first one served in seven seconds i
didn't create that but i introduced that
to american and now everyone has it
[Music]
i met alice when i she came to the
mandarin and one thing another i'm a
hummer
i'm alice waters and i'm the owner of
chipotle's restaurant i've known cecilia
almost 50 years
it's done it's done cecilia's restaurant
was incredibly important
and so many people came there
and learned
and opened
chinese restaurants or
taught cooking you want the junior juice
[Music]
so this way all the juice comes out
her food is very delicious and if it is
a little strange she'll tell you a story
about it
and you'll want to try it
every time i have a meal with cecilia i
learned something
i don't get all the credit
but i think i did something
people always said you put this in the
menu i think americans don't like it i
said
good food is good food
doesn't matter you're american and
chinese you put good food i think
everybody will like it don't you say
[Music]
[Music]
you